This story begins with a random encounter with history. Our senior producer, Brian Reed, was spending a lot of time in Alabama a few years back doing reporting. And one morning he went for a jog near his hotel-- he was in Tuscaloosa-- and he got to this park.
这个故事始于一次与历史的偶然相遇。几年前，我们的资深制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）在阿拉巴马州做报道，花了很长时间待在那里。一天早上，他在下榻的塔斯卡卢萨（Tuscaloosa）酒店附近慢跑，来到了一座公园。
Where the ruins of the old state capitol are. And then I ran down this little pathway down the hill, and I saw this marker, one of those historical markers. And I have never forgotten this thing. Like, it stayed with me. And every time I went back to Tuscaloosa, which was a number of times, I would go, at some point during the trip, walk over and read it again. I brought my wife one time. I brought her to see it, a friend. I've been there a bunch.
那里有旧州议会大厦的遗迹。然后我沿着山坡上的一条小路跑下去，看到了一个标记，就是那种历史地标。我从未忘记过这个东西，它一直萦绕在我心头。每当我回到塔斯卡卢萨——我去过很多次——旅行期间总会找个时间走过去再读一遍。有一次我带妻子去看，还有一次带了个朋友。我去过那里好多次。
It made an impression.
它给人留下了深刻的印象。
Yes.
是的。
So you have the text here, I know.
所以我知道你这里有原文。
Yeah. So the marker's titled "The Indian Fires Are Going Out," in quotes. And it explains that the Trail of Tears led thousands of Creek Indians through Tuscaloosa, back when it was the capital of Alabama, on their way to the West as they were being driven from that part of the country.
是的。这个地标题为“印第安之火正在熄灭”（The Indian Fires Are Going Out），并加上了引号。它解释说，在阿拉巴马州曾是首府的时候，数千名克里克印第安人（Creek Indians）在被迫离开该地区前往西部的途中，经过了塔斯卡卢萨，也就是所谓的“眼泪之路”（Trail of Tears）。
Mm-hm. And their homelands.
嗯。还有他们的家园。
Yeah, and their homelands. And during that time, a Creek chief addressed the legislature on their way out of the state with these words. He gave this speech. Quote, "I come here, brothers, to see the great house of Alabama and the men who make the laws and to say farewell in brotherly kindness before I go to the far West where my people are now going. In time gone by, I have thought that the white men wanted to bring burden and ache of heart among my people in driving them from their homes and yoking them with laws they do not understand. But I have now become satisfied that they are not unfriendly toward us, but that they wish us well.
是的，还有他们的家园。在那段时间里，一位克里克酋长在离开州境前向议会发表了讲话。他发表了这篇演讲，引用如下：“兄弟们，我来到这里，是为了看看伟大的阿拉巴马之家以及制定法律的人们，并在我前往我族人现在正在前往的远方西部之前，怀着兄弟般的善意告别。在过去的日子里，我曾以为白人想要在驱逐我族人离开家园，并给他们套上他们不理解的法律时，带给他们负担和心痛。但我现在已经确信，他们对我们并非不友好，而是希望我们一切安好。”
In these lands of Alabama, which have belonged to my forefathers and where their bones lie buried, I see that the Indian fires are going out. Soon they will be cold. New fires are lighting in the West for us, they say, and we will go there. I do not believe our great Father means to harm his red children, but that he wishes us well. We leave behind our goodwill to the people of Alabama who build the great houses and to the men who make the laws. This is all I have to say."
“在这些属于我祖先的阿拉巴马土地上，在他们的骸骨安葬之处，我看到印第安之火正在熄灭。很快它们就会变冷。据说，西部正在为我们点燃新的火焰，我们将去往那里。我不相信我们伟大的父亲有意伤害他的红皮肤子民，而是希望我们一切安好。我们留下对阿拉巴马人民的善意，是他们建造了伟大的房屋，也是他们制定了法律。这就是我要说的全部。”
And what do you make-- what a strange speech to make, as you're being exiled, to the people who are exiling you.
你对此有何看法——在被流放时，对那些流放你的人发表这样奇怪的演讲。
Exactly. Yeah, that's what struck me about it. I mean, first of all, super sad. And I found it very moving. But also, I read it and reread it, and I just wondered, is this speech kind of subversive in some way? Was this chief standing there in front of the Alabama state legislature, which was partially responsible for kicking his people out, and kind of mocking them slightly or being slightly sarcastic in this speech? Especially this part, "In time gone by, I have thought that the white men wanted to bring burden and ache of heart among my people in driving them from their homes and yoking them with laws they do not understand. But I have now become satisfied that they're not unfriendly toward us, that they wish us well."
确实。是的，这就是让我感到震惊的地方。我的意思是，首先，这非常悲伤。我觉得这非常感人。但我也读了又读，我只是想知道，这篇演讲在某种程度上是否是一种反讽？这位酋长站在阿拉巴马州立法机构面前，而该机构对驱逐他的族人负有部分责任，他是在演讲中稍微嘲弄他们，或者稍微讽刺他们吗？尤其是这一部分：“在过去的日子里，我曾以为白人想要在驱逐我族人离开家园，并给他们套上他们不理解的法律时，带给他们负担和心痛。但我现在已经确信，他们对我们并非不友好，而是希望我们一切安好。”
Right.
对。
Like he's saying, you guys have yoked us with your laws and driven us from our homes, but we know you wish us well. And I just wondered if there was something slightly arch about that.
就像他是在说，你们用你们的法律套住了我们，把我们赶出了家园，但我们知道你们希望我们好。我只是想知道这其中是否带有一种狡黠。
Something arch that went right over the heads of the legislators at the time and also over the heads of the Alabama Historical Association when they approved this marker over a century and a half later. And so recently, Brian decided to look into it. What did the chief mean? Did he say it under duress? Did this even happen? And what we found was, yes, the speech really did occur in the Muskogee language, interpreted into English at the legislature. He found the primary source for us knowing about it-- the only source-- a newspaper article in The Huntsville Democrat in 1835. It says legislators teared up at the speech.
一种让当时的立法者完全没听出来，甚至在一个半多世纪后，阿拉巴马州历史协会在批准这个地标时也没有听出来的狡黠。所以最近，布莱恩决定深入调查一下。酋长是什么意思？他是在胁迫下说的吗？这真的发生过吗？我们发现，是的，演讲确实是在州议会上用马斯科吉语（Muskogee）发表的，并被翻译成英语。他为我们找到了了解此事的唯一原始来源——1835年《亨茨维尔民主党人报》（The Huntsville Democrat）上的一篇文章。文中说，议员们在听演讲时流下了眼泪。
And I talked to several historians, including two experts who are Creek themselves, and there does not seem to be evidence that this was sarcastic.
我和几位历史学家谈过，包括两位本身就是克里克人的专家，似乎没有证据表明这是讽刺。
So but the people who are Creek, what did they make of it? What did they say to you about it?
那么，那些克里克人对此有何看法？他们对你说了什么？
Well, I talked to one woman, named RaeLynn Butler. She's the manager of historic and cultural preservation at the Muskogee Creek Nation in Oklahoma. She'd never seen the speech before. And she lives in Oklahoma. Her ancestors were part of this group of people who left Alabama at this time and came to Oklahoma, and she'd never seen the speech before till we sent it to her to ask her about it.
嗯，我和一位名叫雷琳·巴特勒（RaeLynn Butler）的女士谈过。她是俄克拉荷马州马斯科吉克里克族（Muskogee Creek Nation）历史和文化保护部门的经理。她以前从未见过这篇演讲。她住在俄克拉荷马州，她的祖先是当时离开阿拉巴马州前往俄克拉荷马的那群人的一部分，直到我们把演讲发给她并向她询问，她才第一次见到这篇演讲。
I was very confused when I read the speech because--
当我读到这篇演讲时，我感到非常困惑，因为——
Really? You, too?
真的吗？你也一样？
Yes. It did not sound accurate to me. He talks about how we're being driven from our homes, and then, in the same breath, goes on to say, this is for the betterment of our people.
是的。这听起来不像是真的。他谈到我们是如何被赶出家园的，然后在同一句话里又说，这是为了我们人民的利益。
Yeah, so she reacted to the same thing in the speech that I reacted to. So anyway, so she ended up getting her whole team involved at the cultural preservation office, and they started looking through their archives. And she told me, as they were researching, they were hoping to find evidence that this wasn't exactly right, that maybe the interpreter had messed up or something else was wrong about this speech.
是的，所以她对我演讲中的反应做出了同样的反应。总之，她最终让文化保护办公室的整个团队都参与了进来，他们开始查阅档案。她告诉我，他们在研究时，希望能找到证据证明这并不完全正确，也许是口译员弄错了，或者演讲中还有其他错误。
I was hoping for that.
我当时也希望能找到这个。
And you didn't find it.
但你没找到。
No, and we did not find it.
没有，我们没找到。
So the reality is kind of sobering.
所以现实有点让人清醒。
Yes.
是的。
Did it bum you out when you heard about this speech?
当你听说这篇演讲时，你感到沮丧吗？
Yes. I was bummed to read the speech mainly because I felt that it misrepresented the way that I felt and the way I know my family feels about removal or about assimilation. It's just hard to accept the fact that he says, we know you mean us no harm. It just seemed to go a little bit too far. You lose the game, you shake someone's hand to acknowledge a good game and that we lost. But in this speech, to me, it seems like Yoholo Micco is not only shaking their hand, but he's giving them a hug or even a kiss goodbye.
是的。我读到这篇演讲时感到沮丧，主要是因为我觉得它歪曲了我的感受，以及我知道我的家人对迁移或同化所持有的感受。很难接受他说的“我们知道你们对我们没有恶意”。这似乎有点过头了。你输了比赛，你握住对方的手以承认一场精彩的比赛和我们的失利。但在这次演讲中，对我来说，看起来尤霍洛·米科（Yoholo Micco）不仅是在握手，甚至是在给他们一个拥抱，或者甚至是吻别。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
So basically, Brian stumbled upon this random bit of history three years ago. He started sharing it with people who usually had just as strong a reaction as he had-- reactions of various kinds. And it kind of ricocheted around from person to person, piercing into each one this bullet of information from the past.
所以基本上，布莱恩三年前偶然发现了这段随机的历史。他开始与人们分享，这些人通常和他有一样强烈的反应——各种各样的反应。它就像从一个人传到另一个人手中，将来自过去的一枚信息弹打入每个人的心中。
And since we don't actually know a lot about this speech-- we don't know for sure which chief it was, we don't know why he said it, the only account of it comes from this one newspaper reporter and leaves crucial questions unanswered-- in the end, it's unclear what to think. And even after trying to research it, what we're left with is our own personal reactions and feelings.
由于我们实际上并不真正了解这篇演讲——我们不确定它是哪位酋长，不知道他为什么要这么说，关于它的唯一记录来自这位报社记者，留下了关键的未解之谜——最终，很难评价。即使在尝试研究之后，我们所剩下的也只是我们个人的反应和感受。
Well, today on our program, we have two stories about people who bump into unsettling facts from history. They're both stories that's in a setting designed to actually teach them a little bit of history. And in both of these stories, what they learn is so different from the lessons that they are supposed to get from the past. In fact, it's not even close.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，我们有两个关于人们偶然发现令人不安的历史事实的故事。这两个故事都发生在旨在教授他们一点历史的环境中。在这两个故事中，他们所学到的东西与他们本应从过去得到的教训大相径庭。事实上，根本就不沾边。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请留在这里。
Act One, The Miseducation of Castlemont High.
第一幕，卡斯尔蒙特高中的误导教育（The Miseducation of Castlemont High）。
So we begin with a bunch of students who were taken on a field trip to learn about the past. They were going to see a film that covers some history. They were also going to go ice skating, which a lot of them were especially looking forward to.
我们先从一群去实地考察学习过去的学生说起。他们要去看一部涵盖了部分历史的电影。他们还要去滑冰，其中许多人对此特别期待。
This happened back in 1994. And what happened on that field trip with this group of black and Latino students became kind of a big deal, talked about all across the country because of what they did not learn. BA Parker has worked on our show, and she also incidentally used to be a film professor, and she tells what happened.
这发生在1994年。那次实地考察中发生的事情，对于这群黑人和拉丁裔学生来说成了一件大事，由于他们没有学到什么，这件事在全国范围内引起了讨论。B.A.帕克（B.A. Parker）曾为我们的节目工作，顺便提一下，她以前也是一位电影教授，她讲述了发生的事情。
It was actually a school holiday-- January 17, Martin Luther King Day. And even though there was no school, the teacher was known for his great field trips, so 70 kids showed up. That morning, most of them crowded onto a single bus and headed to the Grand Lake Theatre, this beautiful classic movie house in town. As soon as they got there, they noticed that almost all of the other patrons were white. And according to the kids, those patrons noticed them back. Tracy Wilson was one of the students on the field trip, a freshman.
实际上那是学校假期——1月17日，马丁·路德·金纪念日。虽然不上学，但那位老师以出色的实地考察而闻名，所以有70个孩子到了。那天早上，他们大多数人挤进了一辆大巴，前往城里那家漂亮的经典老电影院——大湖剧院（Grand Lake Theatre）。他们一到那里，就注意到几乎所有的其他观众都是白人。据孩子们说，那些观众也注意到了他们。特雷西·威尔逊（Tracy Wilson）是参加此次实地考察的学生之一，当时读高一。
Just the looks that we were receiving.
就是我们受到的那些眼神。
What kind of looks?
什么样的眼神？
In a matter of, what are you doing here? We don't look like anybody else that's standing in line, but no one said anything to us. No, I take that back. There were those bold ones that asked the question. Oh, are you guys on a field trip? Yes. What school are you from? Castlemont. Oh, OK. And you guys are here to watch a movie? Yeah. What movie are you all watching? And then they're like, ah, OK. You know? Then we get into the theater, and downhill from there.
总之就是，你们在这里干什么？我们看起来和排队里的任何人都不一样，但没人对我们说什么。不，我收回刚才的话。有几个大胆的人问了问题。哦，你们是在实地考察吗？是的。你们是哪个学校的？卡斯尔蒙特高中（Castlemont）。哦，好吧。你们是来看电影的？是的。你们要看什么电影？然后他们就说，啊，好吧。你知道吗？然后我们进了剧院，情况就开始走下坡路了。
The movie they were going to see was Schindler's List, a film about the Holocaust. They walked into the theater. It was chaotic. The teacher had made arrangements ahead of time, but no one remembered him calling. So the 70 teenagers just sat where they could, a lot of them in the back. The four chaperones sat in the front-- four of them for 70 kids.
他们要看的电影是《辛德勒的名单》（Schindler's List），一部关于大屠杀的电影。他们走进剧院，里面一片混乱。老师提前做了安排，但没人记得他打过电话。所以70个青少年就随便坐下，很多人坐在后面。四名带队老师坐在前面——70个孩子配四名老师。
If you're not familiar with Schindler's List, basically, Oskar Schindler, a real-life German businessman played by Liam Neeson, tricks the Nazis into letting him save 1,200 Jewish people in Poland. But that plot isn't clear for a long, long time. And it's artsy in the beginning, almost impenetrable. At least, that's how I felt when I was a teenager and my teacher showed us the film. Long shots with nobody talking, and you don't know what's going on. And it's three hours long and in black and white. At 14, Tracy felt the same way.
如果你不熟悉《辛德勒的名单》，基本上，奥斯卡·辛德勒（Oskar Schindler），一位由连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）扮演的真实德国商人，诱骗纳粹让他拯救了波兰的1200名犹太人。但这个情节在很长一段时间里并不清晰。开头很有艺术感，几乎让人看不懂。至少，我十几岁时老师给我们放这部电影时我是这种感觉。长镜头，没人说话，你不知道发生了什么。而且片长三个小时，还是黑白的。14岁时，特雷西也有同样的感觉。
It opened up with a candle.
它以一支蜡烛开头。
[MATCH STRIKING]
[火柴点燃声]
And I was like, OK.
然后我心想，好吧。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语说话声]
I mean, to us, we were probably like, oh God, black and white. Where are the subtitles? Is this a foreign film? Is this a documentary? Oh God, we have to sit through this to go skating?
我的意思是，对我们来说，我们可能在想，天哪，黑白的。字幕在哪？这是外语片吗？这是纪录片吗？天哪，我们要为了去滑冰而硬撑着看完这个吗？
Well, I remember I was seeing a movie that was in black and white.
嗯，我记得我是在看一部黑白电影。
This is Tanzania Enskip, also a freshman on the field trip. Today, she's a teacher.
这是坦桑尼亚·恩斯基普（Tanzania Enskip），也是参加实地考察的高一学生。今天，她是一名教师。
A lot of violence. There was a lot of violence in the movie. And I remember seeing a lot of things that high school kids shouldn't be seeing. I remember one scene. I was like, wait a minute. That should only be in sex education, not on this screen. A lot of kids were like, oh, my God.
很多暴力。电影里有很多暴力。我记得看到很多高中生不该看到的东西。我记得有一个场景，我当时想，等等。那应该只出现在性教育里，而不是在大屏幕上。很多孩子当时都说，天哪。
For a film about a concentration camp, Schindler's List has a fair amount of sex and titillating nudity in it, which, again, weird thing to show a bunch of high school kids on a field trip. This is Tracy.
作为一部关于集中营的电影，《辛德勒的名单》里有相当多的性和令人垂涎的裸露镜头，这又是一件奇怪的事情，竟然在实地考察时放给一群高中生看。这是特雷西。
Yeah. We were probably-- no, I wouldn't say probably-- we were definitely unruly. It doesn't matter what type of movie it is, people talk. And we didn't want to be there, so probably heard some [CLICKS TONGUE] aw, man, teeth-sucking, attitude.
是的。我们可能——不，我不会说可能——我们绝对是不守纪律的。不管是什么电影，人们都会说话。我们不想待在那里，所以可能听到了一些[啧舌声]噢，天哪，那种吸牙齿声、态度消极的声音。
All the kids admit today they didn't behave appropriately during the movie. They were restless. They talked and horsed around with each other. Some went out to get drinks and popcorn. Others even snuck into other movies. House Party 3 was also playing that day. Those who stayed in the theater were shushed several times by the other patrons and also an usher and a chaperone. When one of the moviegoers told them to be quiet, they reportedly bombarded him with popcorn.
今天所有的孩子都承认他们在电影期间表现得不够规矩。他们坐立不安，聊天打闹，有些人出去买饮料和爆米花，还有一些人溜进了其他影厅。那天《家庭派对3》（House Party 3）也在上映。那些留在影院里的人被其他观众、领队和带队老师嘘了好几次。当其中一名观众让他们安静时，据报道他们向他投掷了爆米花。
I do recall a scene where the young Jewish girl is talking to the German soldiers.
我确实记得一个小女孩和德国士兵交谈的场景。
Nathanial Osborne was a senior when he went on the field trip. Now he teaches special education. The Jewish woman in the scene he's talking about was the foreman on a construction project.
纳撒尼尔·奥斯本（Nathanial Osborne）去参加实地考察时读高三。现在他是一名特殊教育老师。他提到的那个场景里的犹太妇女是建筑项目的工头。
They were building a concentration camp. And the way they were building it was incorrect. She said it was going to cave in.
他们正在建造一个集中营。他们建造的方式是不正确的。她说它会塌方。
Herr Kommandant, the entire foundation has to be torn down and re-poured. If not--
长官，整个地基必须拆除并重新浇筑。如果不——
So she was expressing that to them. The general or the guy in charge there--
所以她正在向他们表达这一点。负责的将军或者那个人——
That would be Ralph Fiennes in the film.
那是电影里的拉尔夫·费因斯（Ralph Fiennes）。
You know, looked at her.
你知道，看着她。
And you are an engineer?
你是工程师吗？
Looked at his constituents.
看着他的手下。
Unterscharfuehrer!
下士！
Ja wohl?
在！
And--
然后——
Shoot her.
射杀她。
--then he told them to shoot her.
——然后他告诉他们射杀她。
And I remember I heard somebody says, oh my God, he's not going to shoot her.
我记得我听到有人说，天哪，他不会真开枪射她吧。
This is Tanzania.
这是坦桑尼亚。
Then one of the kids said that out loud. And I was thinking the same thing in my head. I said, he's not going to shoot this woman. She's just trying to try to let them know that they're doing something incorrectly.
然后其中一个孩子大声说了出来。我心里也是这么想的。我说，他不会射杀这个女人的。她只是想让他们知道他们做错了。
I'm only trying to do my job.
我只是在尽我的职责。
Ja. I'm doing mine.
是啊。我也在尽我的职责。
Sir, she's foreman of construction.
长官，她是施工工头。
We're not going to have arguments with these people.
我们不会和这些人争论。
And the guy simply pulled out his gun and shot her.
然后那个人直接掏出枪射杀了她。
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
That's when I remember a lot of students were like, oh! Oh, my God! Oh! He shot her! Whoa!
那时候我记得很多学生都在喊，噢！天哪！噢！他开枪了！哇！
Tracy Wilson.
特雷西·威尔逊。
Back then, what did we say? Dang! You know? Or, man, that was crazy. Or--
当时，我们说了什么？糟了！你知道吗？或者，伙计，那太疯狂了。或者——
What one of the Castlemont kids-- we don't know who-- actually said-- the five words that would come to define this incident-- "Oh, man. That was cold."
其中一个卡斯尔蒙特的孩子——我们不知道是谁——确实说了那句定义了这次事件的五个词——“噢，伙计。那太冷血了。”（Oh, man. That was cold.）
But he probably said it as, Aw, man. That was cold.
但他可能说的是，噢，伙计。那太冷血了。
He said it really loud, I believe. He was like, Aw, man. That was cold.
我相信他喊得很大声。他是说，噢，伙计。那太冷血了。
And just quickly, there was something else about the scene-- the way the actress fell after she was shot. She bounces abruptly, up and down again, into the snow. It looks unnatural.
还有一件事，那个场景——女演员被枪杀后倒下的样子。她突然弹了一下，又上下颠簸了一下，倒进雪里。看起来很不自然。
Her body was very involved. Like, OK, that's a bit much. As we would say nowadays, extra.
她的身体动作太夸张了。就像是，好吧，这有点过了。就像我们现在说的，太“加戏”了。
And that's when I recall the giggle, shall I say.
就在那时，我记得有人发出了咯咯笑声。
Some kids in the theater laughing while blood poured out of the woman's head.
剧院里有些孩子在鲜血从女人的头上涌出时发出了笑声。
It wasn't at the fact that she got shot. It was her overdramatizing being shot.
那不是因为她被射杀，而是因为她被射杀时的过度表演。
And so then what happened?
那后来发生了什么？
You would see some people get up that were not students and head out the theater.
你会看到一些不是学生的观众起身离开了影院。
I was in my office upstairs, and I decided to go downstairs and get a cup of coffee.
我在楼上的办公室里，我决定下楼去喝杯咖啡。
This is Allen Michaan, the owner of the Grand Lake Theatre.
这是大湖剧院的老板艾伦·米尚（Allen Michaan）。
I went down into the lobby, and there were several dozen very angry, agitated people that were screaming at the manager-- what are you going to do about this? This is outrageous. You've got to do something about this. Angry. They were furious. And there was one woman that was in tears.
我下到大厅，有几十个非常生气、激动的人在对经理尖叫——你打算怎么处理这件事？这太离谱了。你必须采取行动。他们非常愤怒。有一位女士还在哭。
Allen asked the manager what was going on. The manager told him. There were 500 people in the theater that day watching one of the most upsetting films of the 20th century, and some of them-- the teenagers-- were laughing and carrying on. And these people in the lobby, some of them told Allen they were family of Holocaust survivors.
艾伦问经理发生了什么事。经理告诉了他。那天剧院里有500人在看一部20世纪最令人不安的电影，而其中的一些人——那些青少年——却在嬉笑打闹。大厅里的那些人，有些人告诉艾伦他们是大屠杀幸存者的家属。
And I only thought of one thing, and that is, I have a riot situation on my hands. So I went into the projection room and I told projectionist, I said, stop the film.
我当时只想到了一件事，那就是，我手里正面临着一场骚乱。所以我走进放映室，告诉放映员，我说，停止放映。
I remember the lights coming on.
我记得灯光亮了起来。
And I went out into the auditorium.
然后我走到礼堂里。
A guy walking up on the stage.
一个男人走上舞台。
And I said, would the class field trip from Castlemont School please assemble in the lobby?
我说，请卡斯尔蒙特高中的实地考察班级集合到大厅里。
And we were officially kicked out.
我们就这样被正式赶了出来。
Again, this is Tracy.
再一次，这是特雷西。
I think there might have been applause. That was so uncomfortable.
我想当时可能还有掌声。那太尴尬了。
Allen, the theater owner, didn't know when he stopped the movie that the Castlemont students were kids of color, mostly black. But Tanzania told me and my producer, Sean Cole, that, as the students walked out of the theater, the audience definitely knew it.
剧院老板艾伦在停止电影时并不知道卡斯尔蒙特的学生是有色人种，主要是黑人。但坦桑尼亚告诉我，我和我的制作人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole），当学生们走出影院时，观众们绝对知道这一点。
People were clapping. They were applauding. I remember I walked past one gentleman. He told me to go back to Africa.
人们在鼓掌。他们在欢呼。我记得我走过一位绅士身边。他告诉我滚回非洲去。
[GASPS]
[倒吸一口凉气]
What?
什么？
Yeah. I said, whoa. I said, wait a minute. I didn't do anything. That's all I could say. I remember I said, I didn't even do anything. But yeah, it was a gentleman. Becaust I remember I was walking back up, and he was on my left. I felt embarrassed.
是的。我说，哇。我说，等一下。我什么都没做。我只能说这些。我记得我说，我甚至什么都没做。但是的，那是一位绅士。因为我记得我走回去的时候，他在我的左边。我感到很尴尬。
I get that. I was also a black teenager who went to the movies with her friends, and there was always a feeling of being policed or policing yourself if you're young, brown, and carefree in a white space. That can harden you really quick. Tracy again.
我明白。我也是一个和朋友去看电影的黑人少女，如果你年轻、棕色皮肤且无忧无虑地出现在一个白人空间里，总会有一种被监视或自我审查的感觉。这会很快让你变得坚硬。再次听到特雷西的声音。
At that point, I was, for lack of a better term, pissed off. You're clapping? We're kids, and you're adults. But now that I'm an adult, I could see why people were clapping. We were offensive in some of our actions. And with the movie being what it was, it makes sense to me now, most definitely. 15? No.
在那一刻，我，用一个更好的词来形容，就是气炸了。你们在鼓掌？我们是孩子，而你们是成年人。但现在我长大了，我能明白为什么人们会鼓掌。我们的某些行为确实令人反感。鉴于这部电影的内容，我现在完全理解了。15岁时？不。
Again, Tanzania.
再次是坦桑尼亚。
It's starting to come back to me now, everything. And when we were outside in front of the theater waiting on the bus to come back and pick us up, they told us we couldn't wait in front of the theater. And I felt embarrassed by that. I felt bad about it because I said, wow, we're not even good enough to just wait here?
我开始想起来了，一切都回来了。当我们站在剧院外面等大巴来接我们时，他们告诉我们不能在剧院门前等。我为此感到羞愧。我感到很难过，因为我说，哇，我们甚至连在这里等候的资格都没有吗？
They didn't go skating. Two days after that, Tanzania remembers she was walking to school.
他们没去滑冰。在那之后两天，坦桑尼亚记得她正走去学校。
I'm about to get ready to go to class. Let me grab a juice. And I stopped by a store that was close by the school, and I looked down at the newspapers. And it was saying, Castlemont High School students get kicked out the theater.
我正准备去上课。让我去拿杯果汁。我在学校附近的一家店停下来，看着报纸。上面写着，卡斯尔蒙特高中的学生被赶出剧院。
They were in the newspaper on the front page at the very top.
他们在报纸头版的最上面。
And I said, wait a minute. We're bigger than the earthquake?
我说，等一下。我们比地震还重要吗？
There'd been a huge earthquake in California the day before-- 6.7 magnitude. 57 people died. That was on the front page too, below the story about Castlemont.
加州前一天发生了一场大地震——6.7级。57人死亡。那也在头版，在关于卡斯尔蒙特的故事下面。
All we did was get kicked out of the theater. I was like, how are we bigger than the earthquake? That should be headline news.
我们不过是被赶出了剧院。我在想，我们怎么比地震还重要？那才应该是头条新闻。
The article read, "To the horror of many in the audience during Monday's matinee, some of the African-American and Latino teenagers seemed to laugh and applaud at scenes depicting Nazi atrocities." It went on, "People attending the film were shocked and angry by what they felt was insensitivity to the Holocaust." Other news organizations picked up the story as a theater-going version of a hate crime, that dozens of black and Latino kids in Oakland were cheering on the murder of Jewish people.
文章写道：“周一的日场电影期间，观众中很多人感到惊恐，一些非裔和拉丁裔青少年似乎在纳粹暴行的场景中嬉笑和鼓掌。”接着写道：“观看电影的人对他们所感受到的对大屠杀的不敏感感到震惊和愤怒。”其他新闻机构也跟进了这个故事，称这是一起发生在剧院的仇恨犯罪，称奥克兰的几十名黑人和拉丁裔孩子在为屠杀犹太人喝彩。
Hello, caller. You're on the air.
你好，听众。你在直播中。
Hi. I was in the audience with my 13-year-old son and two other friends.
嗨。我和我13岁的儿子还有另外两个朋友在观众席里。
This is from a local call-in show, Flashpoints, that was featured in a documentary called Blacks and Jews from the mid-90s.
这是来自当地一个直播节目《焦点》（Flashpoints），该节目在90年代中期的一部名为《黑人与犹太人》（Blacks and Jews）的纪录片中出现过。
And I was going like, who spends money to see a film on the Holocaust just to disrupt it? And I thought, are these Nazi sympathizers? I couldn't understand who these people were.
当时我想，谁会花钱去看一部关于大屠杀的电影只为了扰乱它呢？我心想，这些人是纳粹同情者吗？我无法理解这些人是谁。
From this point, what actually happened in that theater and the motivations of the kids who were there became less important than how other people chose to see them. They weren't kids who goofed off on a field trip. They were African-American and Latino teenagers applauding at Nazi atrocities. They were anti-Semites.
从这一点来看，剧院里到底发生了什么以及孩子们在那里的动机，变得不如其他人如何选择看待他们那么重要了。他们不是实地考察中调皮的孩子。他们是为纳粹暴行鼓掌的非裔和拉丁裔青少年。他们是反犹分子。
I was just like, wait a minute. That's not me.
我当时就想，等一下。那不是我。
Tanzania didn't even know back then what anti-Semitic meant.
坦桑尼亚当时甚至不知道“反犹太”是什么意思。
If you would have asked me when I was 15, I would've told you no. I would have been like, what is that? What is that word? What does that mean? But after hearing it, though, you look it up in a dictionary, and you figure out what it is.
如果你在我15岁时问我，我会告诉你不知道。我会说，那是什么？那个词是什么意思？但在听到之后，你去查字典，你就明白它是什么了。
Yeah. That's a hell of a way to learn it.
是啊。那真是学习这个词的可怕方式。
Yeah.
是的。
Jewish people just weren't on their radar-- to hate, to love, anything. Nathaniel didn't even know if he'd ever met someone who was Jewish.
犹太人根本不在他们的认知范围之内——无论是仇恨、爱还是其他什么。纳撒尼尔甚至不知道他是否见过犹太人。
No. And if I did, I didn't know they were Jewish.
不。如果见过，我也没发现他们是犹太人。
Did you know that some of your white teachers happened to be Jewish or anything?
你知道你的一些白人老师恰好是犹太人吗？
No. I want to say Mr. Finkelstein. That's what I want to say had some Jewish ties.
不。我想说芬克尔斯坦（Finkelstein）先生。我想说他可能和犹太人有联系。
That sounds about right.
这听起来很对。
But, no.
但是，没有。
There was another thing the students didn't know about-- the Holocaust. They got an hour-long lesson on the basics before the field trip, but that was it. Some of them had learned a little bit about it in middle school a few years earlier. Others had never learned the first thing about it. One boy reportedly thought the Holocaust meant the US bombing of Hiroshima in 1945.
还有一件事是学生们不知道的——大屠杀。实地考察前他们上了一小时的基础课，但仅此而已。他们中有些人几年前在中学时学到了一点点。其他人以前从未听说过。据报道，有个男孩甚至认为大屠杀是指美国1945年对广岛的轰炸。
Within Castlemont, what happened on the field trip just became known as "the incident." And everybody was talking about it-- in class, outside of class. It was clear the administration had to respond publicly. And the way they chose to respond was to say that these kids, who'd grown up in the rough, open flatlands, had seen so much violence-- seen people shot, had guns pulled on them-- that they were desensitized to it.
在卡斯尔蒙特，实地考察中发生的事情被称为“事件”。每个人都在谈论它——在课堂内，课堂外。很明显，校方必须公开回应。他们选择的回应方式是说，这些在粗野、开放的平原地区长大的孩子，见过了太多的暴力——见过有人被射杀，被枪指着——所以对暴力麻木了。
One Jewish Castlemont teacher told The LA Times, "They're not Afro-American kids laughing at Jewish horror, they're the inner-city hip-hop generation desensitized to violence because they see it every day." The staff wasn't alone in pushing this theory. It was a dominant explanation in the media. The whole story was told as a morality tale about black teens and what was wrong with them. But Tanzania basically said that doesn't make any sense.
一位犹太卡斯尔蒙特老师告诉《洛杉矶时报》：“他们不是嘲笑犹太恐怖的非裔美国孩子，他们是内城的嘻哈一代，因为每天都看到暴力而对暴力脱敏了。”教职员工并不是唯一提出这个理论的人。这是媒体中占据主导地位的解释。整个故事被讲述成一个关于黑人青少年的道德故事，以及他们有什么问题。但坦桑尼亚基本上说这完全说不通。
I mean, yeah. Yeah, they've seen a lot of violence, but when you see it, it's not a laughing matter. We're not numb to it. You know, we have empathy. We have all that.
我的意思是，是的。是的，他们见识过很多暴力，但当你看到它时，那不是什么好笑的事。我们并非对它麻木。你知道，我们有共情能力。我们拥有这一切。
It's just when you're seeing it and you're looking at it, it's like, how do you cope with it? And I remember watching the movie. And it's like, my emotions, I was like, how do I handle that? And like you said, the one student was like, oh wow, that was cold.
只是当你看到它并审视它时，就像是，你如何应对它？我记得看这部电影的时候。就像，我的情绪，我在想，我该如何处理这些？正如你所说的，其中一个学生说，噢哇，那太冷血了。
It was cold. Murdering someone for no reason is cold. That was an appropriate reaction. In fact, one of the school administrators said she was happy the students reacted that way because she knew it had affected them.
确实冷血。无缘无故谋杀某人是冷血的。这是一种恰当的反应。事实上，学校的一位行政人员说她很高兴学生们有这种反应，因为她知道这触动了他们。
After the newspaper articles, a barrage of angry phone calls flooded into Castlemont High School, many of them from the local Jewish community. People were disappointed in the students and the faculty. The high school administration decided it needed to nip this controversy in the bud. Or they decided the kids needed to nip this controversy in the bud. So that same week as the field trip, by the end of the week, they organized a press conference, and the students were strongly encouraged to speak.
报纸文章刊登后，卡斯尔蒙特高中涌入了大量的愤怒电话，很多来自当地的犹太社区。人们对学生和教师感到失望。高中管理部门决定需要将这场争议扼杀在摇篮里。或者他们决定孩子们需要将这场争议扼杀在摇篮里。所以在那周，也就是实地考察那周结束时，他们组织了一场新闻发布会，学生们被强烈鼓励发言。
Hi, I'm the student body president at Castlemont High, Kandi Stewart, and I would like to introduce our student speakers for today, which is Tracy Wilson--
嗨，我是卡斯尔蒙特高中的学生会主席坎迪·斯图尔特（Kandi Stewart），我想介绍我们今天的学生发言人，她就是特雷西·威尔逊——
Four of the students from the field trip, who were also members of the student council, sat at a table in front of news cameras. They were dressed professionally. Imagine a '90s era high school picture day. 17-year-old Nathaniel, who you heard earlier, was in a crisp white shirt and black necktie. Tracy Wilson wore a dark navy dress with puffy shoulders and brass buttons, looking like someone much older than she was.
四名参加实地考察也是学生会成员的学生坐在新闻摄像机前的一张桌子旁。他们穿着职业装。想象一下90年代的高中照片日。你刚才听到的17岁的纳撒尼尔穿着一件清爽的白衬衫和黑色领带。特雷西·威尔逊穿着一件深蓝色的连衣裙，垫肩，铜扣，看起来比实际年龄成熟得多。
To the management and patrons at the Grand Lake Theatre and anyone else who was offended by our actions, we apologize for any discomfort and pain we may have caused you. We are sorry for the disruption. It was not our intention to offend anyone. We believe our teachers' hearts were in the right place. They wanted to teach us about the Holocaust.
对于大湖剧院的管理层和观众，以及任何其他被我们的行为冒犯的人，我们为我们可能造成的任何不适和痛苦道歉。我们对造成的干扰感到抱歉。我们无意冒犯任何人。我们相信老师们的初衷是好的。他们想教导我们关于大屠杀的知识。
Tracy and the other students took on all the blame. Never once during this press conference did the principal or any of the teachers make a statement.
特雷西和其他学生承担了所有的指责。在这次新闻发布会上，校长或老师们从未发表过声明。
We will never have a chance to make another first impression, but we have to rise above this.
我们永远没有机会再留下第一次印象，但我们必须超越这一点。
Oh, that caused such mess.
噢，那引起了如此大的混乱。
This is Tracy in the present day.
这是现在的特雷西。
This needed to be fixed. And if it takes an apology so we can get this to blow over, so be it. Let's get the kids to apologize. But that didn't seem to calm the storm.
这需要被解决。如果道歉能让这件事平息，那就这样吧。让孩子们道歉吧。但这似乎并没有平息这场风暴。
For one thing, a lot more media picked up the story-- CNN, The Washington Post, The New York Times-- but the anger and reprimands just kept coming over the next few days and weeks. In a letter to The LA Times, a boardmember of the Malibu Jewish Center and Synagogue wrote, quote, "I feel angry that anyone old enough to understand the meaning of man's inhumanity to man could act as callous as these kids apparently acted." Another reader wrote, "There is no excuse for what those kids did-- not lack of education, not lack of being prepared, nothing." One of the four students who apologized on camera received death threats in the mail.
首先，更多的媒体跟进了这个故事——CNN，《华盛顿邮报》，《纽约时报》——但在接下来的几天和几周里，愤怒和谴责接踵而至。在给《洛杉矶时报》的一封信中，马里布犹太中心和犹太教堂的一位董事会成员写道：“我感到愤怒，任何到了能理解人类对人类的不人道含义的年纪的人，怎么能像这些孩子表现得那样冷漠。”另一位读者写道：“这些孩子的所作所为没有任何借口——不是教育匮乏，不是缺乏准备，什么都没有。”四名在镜头前道歉的学生中，有一名收到了邮寄的死亡威胁。
Anisa Rasheed taught English and African History at Castlemont at the time.
安妮莎·拉希德（Anisa Rasheed）当时在卡斯尔蒙特教英语和非洲历史。
It seemed like it made it worse. And some entities felt that the kids didn't apologize for what they felt they should be apologizing for.
这看起来让事情变得更糟了。一些实体认为孩子们并没有为他们应该道歉的事情道歉。
What did they feel they should be apologizing for?
他们觉得他们应该为之道歉的是什么？
The kids were trying to apologize for their behavior, for the way that they behaved. But it felt like the greater powers that be, or the certain elements, they wanted the kids to apologize for their feeling and their thinking, that they should apologize and own being insensitive to the pain and suffering of Jewish people, and that they're sorry for that and they'll never do it again. And now that they've been reprimanded, they're going to try to be better people.
孩子们试图为他们的行为、他们的举止道歉。但感觉上，更大的权力机构，或者某些因素，他们想要孩子们为他们的感受和想法道歉，他们认为孩子们应该道歉并承认对犹太人的痛苦和苦难麻木不仁，并且他们为此感到抱歉，以后永远不会再这样做了。现在他们受到了谴责，他们将尝试成为更好的人。
The kids didn't own being insensitive to the pain and suffering of the Jewish people. But to be fair, they hadn't witnessed the full spectrum of the pain and suffering of the Jewish people yet. There were still two more hours and 20 minutes of the film that they never got through-- the film that they hadn't been properly prepared for and that they hadn't been taught.
孩子们并不认为自己对犹太人的痛苦和苦难麻木不仁。但平心而论，他们还没有见识过犹太人痛苦和苦难的全貌。电影还有两个小时20分钟他们没看完——这部他们没做好充分准备，也没被教导过的电影。
From their perspective, here's what happened. They misbehaved on a field trip, and they said they were sorry. And now they were getting death threats for not being sorry in the right way. Now they were fed up and defensive. They were tired of talking about how ignorant they were. They wanted to talk about something else. There had been a lot of discussion about what happened a while ago to a persecuted minority who wasn't them. And so when some Jewish people offered to come to Castlemont to teach them about the Holocaust, they weren't in the mood for moral lectures on someone else's history.
从他们的角度来看，发生了什么：他们在实地考察中行为不端，他们说了对不起。现在他们因为道歉方式不对而受到死亡威胁。现在他们受够了，开始防御。他们厌倦了谈论自己有多无知。他们想谈论点别的。关于一个曾经被迫害的少数群体——那不是他们——发生的事情，已经有了很多讨论。所以当一些犹太人提出要来卡斯尔蒙特教他们关于大屠杀的知识时，他们没有心情听关于别人历史的道德说教。
I don't want to hear anything-- no disrespect, but I don't want to hear anything about anybody else's Holocaust before I hear my own.
我不想听任何东西——无意冒犯，但在听我自己的大屠杀之前，我不想听任何关于别人大屠杀的内容。
This recording is from the Blacks and Jews documentary, which has a long section on Castlemont.
这段录音来自《黑人与犹太人》纪录片，其中有很长一部分关于卡斯尔蒙特的内容。
You cannot sit here and fill me with your knowledge until I have my own.
在我拥有自己的知识之前，你不能坐在这里用你的知识填满我。
As black people, Latinos, and other races, Indians, they don't understand their own Holocaust. We don't understand our own Holocaust, because I'm black and Indian. She's Latino. She's Jamaican-Indian. First, we need to learn about our own Holocaust, and then maybe we can understand your Holocaust.
作为黑人、拉丁裔和其他种族，印第安人，他们不了解自己的大屠杀。我们不了解我们自己的大屠杀，因为我是黑人和印第安混血。她是拉丁裔。她是牙买加和印第安混血。首先，我们需要了解我们自己的大屠杀，然后也许我们才能理解你们的大屠杀。
What about the Trail of Tears, or slavery, or colonialism? They wanted to learn about that. Anisa Rasheed felt the same way as her students. She's the English and History teacher, and she organized a day-long black history teach-in, or African Holocaust Day. There were musicians and African dancers, lectures on ancient Egypt and Jim Crow. One guest teacher explained that racism has 54 components to it. Another, wearing a regal brown and gold dashiki, a kufi, with a leather-bound neck pouch, walked up and down the front of a classroom, commanding students' attention, pointing to placards listing the names of people who had been lynched in the South.
那“眼泪之路”，或奴隶制，或殖民主义呢？他们想学习那个。安妮莎·拉希德和她的学生们感受一样。她是英语和历史老师，她组织了一场全天的黑人历史教学活动，或称“非洲大屠杀日”。有音乐家和非洲舞者，关于古埃及和吉姆·克劳法案（Jim Crow）的讲座。一位客座教师解释说，种族主义有54个组成部分。另一位身穿华丽的棕金相间长袍、戴着无边便帽、脖子上挂着皮囊的人，在教室前走来走去，指挥着学生的注意力，指着列出在南方被私刑处死的人名 placards。
Lynched-- ropes tied around their necks and hung from trees for 100 years-- hung from trees, all these names, black people. This is the Maafa.
私刑——绳子系在脖子上从树上吊死，长达100年——从树上吊死，所有这些名字，黑人。这就是“Maafa”。
Maafa is another word for the African Holocaust. There were dozens of presentations about a variety of topics. But in the movie Blacks and Jews, one of the students talked about one particular aspect of the history of slavery that stuck with her.
“Maafa”是“非洲大屠杀”的另一个词。有几十个关于各种主题的演讲。但在《黑人与犹太人》电影中，其中一名学生谈到了一个让她印象深刻的关于奴隶制历史的特定方面。
Well, I was in one of those classes, and what they were talking about was basically how slave ships were owned by Jews. And he showed us documents from where he had gotten out of Washington DC that stated that. And to me, that laid an impression upon me.
嗯，我在其中一个课堂上，他们谈论的是奴隶船基本上是犹太人拥有的。他向我们展示了文件，那是他从华盛顿特区弄到的。对我来说，这给我留下了深刻的印象。
I think it's safe to assume this particular fact stood out to this girl because Jews were suddenly a trending topic at her school.
我认为可以肯定地说，这个特定的事实引起了这个女孩的注意，因为犹太人突然成了她学校里的热门话题。
Laura Abrams was the school social worker at Castlemont at the time. A lot of kids really liked her. She was 25 years old then. And for the first time, her Jewishness was a topic of interest.
劳拉·艾布拉姆斯（Laura Abrams）当时是卡斯尔蒙特的学校社会工作者。很多孩子真的很喜欢她。她当时25岁。而这是第一次，她的犹太身份成了人们感兴趣的话题。
This was all students wanted to talk about and asked me a lot of questions about. All of the sudden, it was like, oh, are you Jewish? And well, were you raised racist? And, did your family own slaves?
这是所有学生想谈论的，并问了我很多问题。突然之间，就像是，哦，你是犹太人吗？嗯，你是种族主义者养大的吗？你们家族拥有过奴隶吗？
Some kids told Laura they heard Jews were the most racist group. It was hurtful. So though there wasn't any anti-Semitism among the students before the field trip, it seemed like a kind of anti-Semitism was growing at Castlemont High School.
有些孩子告诉劳拉他们听说犹太人是最种族主义的群体。这很伤人。所以虽然实地考察前学生中没有任何反犹太主义，但在卡斯尔蒙特高中，一种反犹太主义似乎正在滋长。
I don't-- I don't want to say that.
我不——我不想这么说。
Again, Tracy.
再次是特雷西。
What I will say is, I remember just kids just being frustrated, and saying things, and not really having a clear understanding of what they're saying.
我想说的是，我记得孩子们只是感到沮丧，说了些话，并没有真正理解他们在说什么。
She's talking about anti-Semitic slurs.
她在谈论反犹太歧视的污言秽语。
You know? Just saying it out of anger because they've heard somebody say it or read it somewhere. But it wasn't like-- you have to understand that a lot of the kids didn't really differentiate Jewish people from all white people, so they weren't necessarily saying, oh, all Jews are blah. No, they were just saying white people. You know, white people this, or blah. And there wasn't any real correction. And I felt like it was allowed. And instead of it being used as a time of enlightenment, it just breeded more ignorance.
你知道吗？只是因为愤怒而说出来，因为他们听过别人这么说或在某处读到过。但并不是像——你必须明白很多孩子并没有真正区分犹太人和所有白人，所以他们不一定是在说，哦，所有犹太人都怎么样。不，他们只是在说白人。你知道，白人这个，或那个。而且没有真正的纠正。我觉得这是被允许的。而不是被用作启蒙的时刻，它反而滋生了更多的无知。
A few months went by, and then some surprising news arrived at Castlemont. Stephen Spielberg was coming for a visit. He and the governor of California at the time, Pete Wilson, had been working on a way to incorporate Schindler's List in a larger curriculum for high schoolers about the Holocaust and slavery. There'd be free screenings of the film and a study guide. These plans were already in the works before the field trip happened, but where better to make the announcement than Castlemont High School?
几个月过去了，然后卡斯尔蒙特传来了一些令人惊讶的消息。史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格（Stephen Spielberg）要来访问。他和当时的加州州长皮特·威尔逊（Pete Wilson）一直在研究如何将《辛德勒的名单》纳入高中生关于大屠杀和奴隶制的更广泛课程中。将会有电影的免费放映和学习指南。这些计划在实地考察发生前就已经在制定中了，但还有什么地方比卡斯尔蒙特高中更适合宣布呢？
So at first glance, this simply looked like another opportunity for Castlemont High School to put this whole thing to rest, or at least to put a positive spin on it. But as with every other turn in this Castlemont Schindler's saga, all it did was enrage pretty much everyone. Days beforehand, a bunch of workers came to campus to carry out this whole beautification campaign. Almost everybody we talked to made a point of mentioning it.
所以乍一看，这看起来只是卡斯尔蒙特高中平息整件事，或者至少为它做正面宣传的另一个机会。但正如卡斯尔蒙特《辛德勒》传奇中的每一次转折一样，它所做的只是激怒了几乎所有人。几天前，一群工人来到校园执行整个美化运动。我们谈过的几乎每个人都提到了它。
Prettying up the place, and cutting the hedges, and painting stuff.
把地方弄得漂亮点，修剪树篱，刷油漆什么的。
Buildings got painted. Landscaping got done.
大楼被刷了漆。景观也被整理了。
And then, of course, the trimming of the hedges and the painting, which I found to be very funny.
当然，还有修剪树篱和刷漆，我觉得这非常滑稽。
Again, Tracy.
再次是特雷西。
It just felt like this big cover-up.
感觉这就像一场巨大的掩盖行动。
What do you mean by that?
你是什么意思？
I mean, to be quite honest, you have the governor there, Mr. Pete Wilson, who was also "Mr Budget-Cut Governor." It would have been great for him to see what his cuts were doing to this urban community, but that's just my thought.
我的意思是，老实说，皮特·威尔逊州长也在场，他也是“预算削减先生”。如果他能看到他的削减对这个城市社区造成的影响，那将非常棒，但这只是我的想法。
It wasn't just her thought. The county in which Oakland sits voted overwhelmingly against Pete Wilson in the 1990 election. It was like 70/30 split. Castlemont kids were black, Pacific Islander, and Latino. Governor Wilson championed one of the harshest anti-immigration laws in California's history, Proposition 187. Many Castlemont kids were low income. Wilson said that welfare, quote, "seduces teenage girls into a life of poverty and encourages irresponsibility." He was also up for re-election.
这不仅仅是她的想法。奥克兰所在的县在1990年的选举中以压倒性多数投票反对皮特·威尔逊。比例大概是70/30。卡斯尔蒙特的孩子们是黑人、太平洋岛民和拉丁裔。州长威尔逊倡导了加州历史上最严厉的反移民法律之一，第187号提案。许多卡斯尔蒙特的孩子是低收入群体。威尔逊说福利，“引诱少女陷入贫困生活并鼓励不负责任的行为。”他当时也要竞选连任。
Cicely Day was a senior at Castlemont back in '94. On the day of the assembly, she roamed the halls, hoping for a Spielberg sighting.
西塞莉·戴（Cicely Day）在94年是卡斯尔蒙特的高三学生。在集会那天，她在走廊里闲逛，希望见到斯皮尔伯格。
And I would run into-- like, all of these government people that worked for education was there. And I would just be like, hi, how are you? And they're like, oh, we're great. I'm like, wow, it's so amazing that you're here today. Are you coming back? Oh, we're just here for the day. Oh, you're not going to come back? Because you sure figured out how to come today. You're not going to come back? Because we need new books, and our lockers are broke, and the bleachers have holes. Can you come back and make sure that gets done? And they would just look at me like, oh no, she didn't. I'm like, oh, yes, I did.
我会碰到——就像，所有那些为教育工作的政府人员都在那。我就说，嗨，你好吗？他们说，哦，我们很好。我说，哇，你们今天来这里真是太棒了。你们还会再来吗？哦，我们只是来一天。哦，你们不会再来了？因为你们确实知道怎么今天来。你们不会再来了？因为我们需要新书，我们的储物柜坏了，看台上有洞。你们能回来确保这些都修好吗？他们就会用那种“哦，不，她没说吧”的眼神看着我。我说，哦，是的，我说了。
Oh, my.
噢，天哪。
Yes, I did. And if I ran into anybody else who I knew had some influence, I was going to say the same thing.
是的，我说了。如果我遇到任何我知道有影响力的人，我都会这么说。
The event itself was a total circus from the beginning. Not only were there all these government officials hanging around, and security, and the national press, but hundreds of protesters marched up and down the street outside the school, many of them from the Nation of Islam.
活动本身从一开始就是一场闹剧。不仅有所有这些政府官员在周围徘徊，还有安保人员和国家媒体，而且数百名抗议者在校门外的街道上来回游行，许多人来自伊斯兰国度（Nation of Islam）。
Give the truth to the youth. Give the truth to the youth. Give the truth to the youth. Let's talk about the Black Holocaust. Let's talk about the Black Holocaust.
把真相给青年。把真相给青年。把真相给青年。让我们谈谈黑人大屠杀。让我们谈谈黑人大屠杀。
One of the protesters was a little more specific.
其中一名抗议者说得更具体一些。
A Zionist Jew-- Steven Spielberg is a Zionist Jew.
犹太复国主义者——史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格是一个犹太复国主义者。
They waved signs around that spanned from the pointed "How can a Zionist Jew teach us about racism and oppression?" to the extremely pointed "Zionist Jews are the new Nazis." Remember, this all began with a field trip to teach kids tolerance.
他们挥舞着标语，从尖锐的“犹太复国主义者怎么能教我们关于种族主义和压迫？”到极度尖锐的“犹太复国主义者是新纳粹”。记住，这一切始于一次教导孩子宽容的实地考察。
Aaron Grumet was a geometry teacher at Castlemont and had been one of the teachers on the original field trip.
亚伦·格鲁梅特（Aaron Grumet）是卡斯尔蒙特的几何老师，也是最初那次实地考察的老师之一。
By the time I'd gotten over to the auditorium, it was overflowing. And a lot of the students couldn't even get in because the auditorium was full. And what I remember was that all the politicians and dignitaries were there and got their seats in the front. And a lot of the students and faculty never got in. And I remember thinking, wow, this is just nuts, you know?
当我走到礼堂时，里面已经挤满了人。很多学生甚至进不去，因为礼堂满了。我记得所有的政客和政要都在那里，坐在前排。很多学生和教职员工根本没进去。我记得我在想，哇，这真是疯了，你知道吗？
Mr. Steven Spielberg and the Governor of the State of California. Let's go-- stand up, ladies and gentlemen. The governor of the state of California is in the building.
史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格先生和加利福尼亚州州长。让我们——站起来，女士们，先生们。加利福尼亚州州长在大楼里。
It was a program befitting of a head of state and a Hollywood icon. There were performances from the students, including a monologue that started off, "Dear Mr. President, I am a woman with three children and no food to eat." Governor Wilson gave a pretty formal recitation about his Holocaust education initiative. And then, fully aware of his place on the food chain, he handed the mic over to the man of the hour.
这是一场足以媲美国家元首和好莱坞偶像的节目。学生们有表演，包括一段独白，开头是：“亲爱的总统先生，我是一个有三个孩子且没饭吃的女人。”州长威尔逊就他的大屠杀教育倡议发表了非常正式的背诵。然后，充分意识到自己在食物链中的位置，他把麦克风交给了当天的焦点人物。
Ladies and gentlemen, the students of Castlemont High School, it gives me great pleasure to introduce to you a man who is helping and who has accomplished great things for film, for education, and for tolerance-- Mr. Steven Spielberg.
女士们，先生们，卡斯尔蒙特高中的学生们，我非常高兴地向你们介绍一位一直在帮助并为电影、教育和宽容事业做出了巨大贡献的人——史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格先生。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Instead of sitting up here on the stage like a performer, I'd like to be right down there in the center, among all of you.
我不想像表演者一样坐在这里，我想就在你们中间，在最中央。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I'd also like to acknowledge the fact that I believe that Castlemont High School has received a very bad rap for what happened that day on Martin Luther King Day.
我也想承认一个事实，我相信卡斯尔蒙特高中因为马丁·路德·金纪念日那天发生的事情而背了黑锅。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And I also think it's very important that that incident that happened-- and by the way, I was thrown out of Ben-Hur when I was a kid for talking, so you know, I kind of know what that was like, I think. I think we have to put this under the heading of the privileges of youth. And I absolutely, when I heard about this incident--
我也认为那天发生的那个事件非常重要——顺便说一下，我小时候因为在电影院说话而被赶出过《宾虚》（Ben-Hur），所以你知道，我想我知道那是什么感觉。我认为我们必须把这归类为青春的特权。而且我绝对，当我听说这个事件时——
He was just so cool.
他真是太酷了。
Again, this is Tracy.
再次是特雷西。
He said that he understood what happened, and that he didn't blame us, and that we were just kids, and that we weren't anti-Semitic, and that the situation just in and of itself was just really, really bad.
他说他理解发生了什么，他不怪我们，我们只是孩子，我们不是反犹分子，而且那个情况本身就非常、非常糟糕。
How did it feel to hear that from an adult?
听到成年人这么说感觉如何？
I mean, it felt great. And the fact that it was him, it was even better, you know? And for him to acknowledge what happened but not place that type of blame on us was great. It gave us-- it gave me relief. I was like, wow. I will see all his movies.
我的意思是，感觉太棒了。而且那个人是他，这感觉更好，你知道吗？他承认发生了什么但没有把那种指责放在我们身上，这太棒了。这给了我们——给了我解脱。我说，哇。我会去看他所有的电影。
It was the first time she felt like someone-- an adult-- was publicly coming to their defense-- wasn't labeling them, didn't accuse them, or condescend towards them, or try to save them. The students of Castlemont had been thrust into a dizzying adult world of bigotry and bylines. And Spielberg did something no one else in the auditorium thought to do, something that students, counter-intuitively, had been yearning for the whole time-- you talk to them like they were kids.
这是她第一次感觉有人——一个成年人——在公开为他们辩护——没有给他们贴标签，没有指责他们，也没有表现得高高在上，或者试图“拯救”他们。卡斯尔蒙特的学生被推入了一个令人眩晕的、充满偏见和头条的成人世界。而斯皮尔伯格做了一件礼堂里其他人都没有想到要做的事情，一件学生们在某种程度上一直渴望的事情——他像对待孩子一样与他们交谈。
And then it was over. Finally, the kids and the teachers could get back to their studies, final exams, preparing for graduation. Or so they thought.
然后结束了。终于，孩子们和老师们可以回到他们的学习、期末考试和准备毕业中了。或者他们是这么认为的。
One afternoon two weeks later, Steven Spielberg came back. This time, it was unannounced-- no media. The kids from the field trip and the chaperones gathered in the school library. Tanzania was there.
两周后的一个下午，史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格回来了。这一次，是未经宣布的——没有媒体。参加实地考察的孩子们和带队老师聚集在学校图书馆。坦桑尼亚也在那里。
And I remember somebody-- I think one of the teachers was recording it. And he asked him to put the camera away. Yeah. And the teacher respectfully put it away.
我记得有人——我想是其中一位老师在录音。他让他把相机收起来。是的。那位老师恭敬地收了起来。
When Spielberg tells you to do something, you do it.
当斯皮尔伯格让你做什么时，你就得做。
You do it. Right.
你得做。没错。
Aaron Grumet, the math teacher, says it was all very hush-hush. Spielberg said he wanted it to be just them-- no hard feelings, no agenda.
数学老师亚伦·格鲁梅特说一切都很保密。斯皮尔伯格说他希望只有他们自己——没有芥蒂，没有议程。
And he opened things up to the floor. And I remember he started talking, asking them questions. And one of them asked why the Jewish people didn't just pretend that they were German so as not to be killed.
他把空间留给了学生们。我记得他开始交谈，向他们提问。其中一个孩子问为什么犹太人不假装他们是德国人，这样就不会被杀害。
That's a good question.
这是个好问题。
It's a very good question. And if you're a person of different color, it's very difficult for you to pretend you're another culture. You can't pretend you're German. You can't pretend you're white. So it was a very, very poignant question on these 14-year-old kids.
这是一个非常好的问题。如果你是一个不同肤色的人，假装你是另一种文化是非常困难的。你不能假装你是德国人。你不能假装你是白人。所以这对14岁的孩子来说是一个非常、非常深刻的问题。
One of the kids asked Spielberg, have you ever made a movie about the Black Holocaust, about slavery? He said no. The kid inquired, well, why not? And Spielberg said, well, maybe I will. Three years later, he released Amistad, about a slave ship. In an email, Steven Spielberg confirmed that one of the reasons he decided to make that film was that student's question.
其中一个孩子问斯皮尔伯格，你有没有拍过关于黑人大屠杀、关于奴隶制的电影？他说没有。那个孩子问，嗯，为什么不呢？斯皮尔伯格说，嗯，也许我会拍。三年后，他发布了关于一艘奴隶船的《断锁怒潮》（Amistad）。在一封电子邮件中，史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格确认，他决定拍摄那部电影的原因之一就是那个学生的问题。
The program to teach Schindler's List to high school students spread across the country. Two years after the Castlemont kids got kicked out of the movie theater, over two million public high school students had seen Schindler's List, and many more since then, including me. I saw Schindler's List twice in school by my 15th birthday. We also read Night by Elie Wiesel and The Diary of Anne Frank and were taken to the Holocaust Museum in DC. They never showed us Amistad in public school in Baltimore.
将《辛德勒的名单》教给高中生的项目传遍了全国。卡斯尔蒙特的学生被赶出电影院两年后，超过两百万公立高中生看过《辛德勒的名单》，此后还有更多，包括我。我在15岁生日之前在学校看了两次《辛德勒的名单》。我们还读了埃利·维塞尔（Elie Wiesel）的《夜》（Night）和《安妮日记》（The Diary of Anne Frank），并被带去了华盛顿特区的大屠杀纪念馆。在巴尔的摩的公立学校，他们从没给我们放过《断锁怒潮》。
The Castlemont kids were the test case for all of this. They eventually did learn something about this one event in Jewish history. They learned other things, too. They learned how white people read them and their behavior and how quickly they get labeled. It's something lots of kids of color learn in lots of ways, but these kids learned it all of a sudden in a really public way.
卡斯尔蒙特的孩子们是所有这一切的测试案例。他们最终确实学到了一些关于犹太历史中这一事件的知识。他们也学到了其他东西。他们学会了白人如何解读他们和他们的行为，以及他们有多容易被贴上标签。这是许多有色人种孩子以各种方式学习到的东西，但这些孩子们突然以一种非常公开的方式学习到了。
They also learned how to steel yourself against all of that. One of the Castlemont kids, who got a death threat in the mail, later hung it on her dorm room wall for motivation. They learned they could push back. You can see that happening in one of my favorite moments from that assembly with the governor and Spielberg. Just a handful of kids were allowed to ask questions, and the questions were vetted and approved by the adults. And then the senior class president, Kandi Stewart, went off script. Here's what she said to the governor of California.
他们还学会了如何让自己坚强起来面对这一切。卡斯尔蒙特的孩子中，有一位收到过死亡威胁邮件的，后来把信挂在她宿舍墙上作为激励。他们学会了可以反击。在我和州长、斯皮尔伯格的那次集会中，我最喜欢的一个时刻你可以看到这一点。只有少数学生被允许提问，问题也都经过大人的审核和批准。然后高三学生会主席坎迪·斯图尔特脱稿了。这是她对加州州长所说的话。
This is to Governor Wilson. I see your visit to Oakland, a city plagued with poverty, from different views. I see it as a failing governor's publicity stunt that enables him to portray--
这是对威尔逊州长的。我对你在奥克兰的访问——一个饱受贫困困扰的城市——有不同的看法。我看它是失败的州长的公关噱头，使他能够将自己刻画成——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
wait a minute-- that enables him to portray himself as a caring politician, embracing the poor, and smothering them with empty promises, coincidentally close to election time. But I also see-- wait a minute-- but I also see the entire political fiasco as an opportunity to vent the anger, and the spite, and the animosity I feel toward your entire time in office. I mean, I want to know was your main purpose in portraying yourself through the streets of my city where you have cut welfare, education, and many young futures, like mine--
等一下——使他能够将自己刻画成一个富有同情心的政治家，拥抱穷人，并用空洞的承诺来掩盖他们，恰逢选举前夕。但我还看到——等一下——但我还看到整个政治闹剧是一个宣泄我对我对你在任期间感受到的愤怒、恶意和敌意的机会。我的意思是，我想知道你在街道上刻画你自己，而你却削减了福利、教育和许多年轻的未来，比如我的——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Kandi got in trouble for this-- was reprimanded by the principal, vilified in letters to the editor, just like the kids had been before. But this time, it was for something she really cared about. Governor Wilson and his policies seemed like a direct threat to things that really mattered to her.
坎迪因此惹上了麻烦——被校长训斥，在读者来信中被诋毁，就像之前的孩子们一样。但这一次，这是因为她真正关心的事情。威尔逊州长和他的政策看起来是对她真正重要的事情的直接威胁。
Well, I won't count on your vote. Let me just say that--
嗯，我不会指望你的选票。让我只想说——
Publicly, throughout the entire Schindler's debacle, it seemed like these stackable burdens were resting squarely on the shoulders of the students. The teachers seemed to come to an agreement that it was the kids' incident, and therefore, the kids were the ones that needed to step out in front of it. And Kandi Stewart seemed to be saying, I'll step in front of it. I'll step right in front of it.
在整个辛德勒的混乱中，从表面上看，这些堆积如山的负担似乎直接压在学生们的肩上。老师们似乎达成了一项协议，这是孩子们的“事件”，因此，孩子们是需要站在前面承担责任的人。而坎迪·斯图尔特似乎在说，我会站在前面。我会直接站在前面。
B.A. Parker in New York City. Coming up, a memorial you didn't want to visit dedicated to an event you wish never happened-- what you can learn from that. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我是纽约市的B.A.帕克。稍后，一个你不想参观的纪念馆，致力于一个你希望从未发生的事件——你可以从中学习到什么。稍后芝加哥公共广播电台将继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program is about what happens when you come across some historical facts presented by people who want you to learn those facts, either from a marker on the side of the road, or maybe a film, or in the case of this next act, a museum. Sometimes, what you get from that experience is very different from what is intended, which brings us to Act Two of our program. Act Two, Exit Through the Gift Shop.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是关于当你偶然发现一些历史事实时会发生什么，这些事实是由希望你学习这些事实的人呈现的，要么来自路边的标记，要么可能是一部电影，或者像下一幕那样，一家博物馆。有时，你从那种经历中得到的与预期的非常不同，这带我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，礼品店出口。
Steve Kandell was an editor at Buzzfeed back in 2014 when the 9/11 Memorial Museum opened in New York City. His sister, Shari, had died in the Twin Towers. And he wrote this for Buzzfeed back when the museum opened.
史蒂夫·坎德尔（Steve Kandell）在2014年纽约市9/11纪念博物馆开馆时是Buzzfeed的编辑。他的姐姐莎丽（Shari）在双子塔中遇难。他在博物馆开馆时为Buzzfeed写了这篇文章。
Quick warning if you're listening with little kids. This piece goes into some detail about 9/11. Also, here in the podcast, there are a couple curse words we have an un-beeped. If you prefer a beeped version of our show, you can find that on our website. Here's Steve Kandell.
如果你和小孩子一起听，快速警告一下。这篇文章详细描述了9/11事件。此外，在这里的播客中，有几处脏话我们没有消音。如果你喜欢我们节目的消音版，可以在我们的网站上找到。这是史蒂夫·坎德尔。
In the chaotic last months of 2001, my father wrote letters to newspapers asking simply that the press stop calling his daughter a hero. The heroes ran into the buildings. She was just a person who happened to have gotten to work a little early on a Tuesday morning. And that was horrible and heartbreaking and difficult enough without the extra weight. On September 21, the day that would have been my sister's 28th birthday, my father gave a eulogy to this effect at her memorial.
在2001年混乱的最后几个月里，我父亲给报社写信，简单地要求媒体停止称他的女儿为英雄。英雄是那些冲进大楼的人。她只是一个恰好在周二早上早一点去上班的人。这对我们来说已经足够可怕、令人心碎和困难了，不需要额外的负担。9月21日，也就是我姐姐28岁生日的那天，我父亲在她的追悼会上发表了对此事的悼词。
In the days and years after, this was less of a mantra than our only way forward, to find a way to separate what happened from what happened to us. We declined participation in most of the ceremonies and pageantry in favor of figuring out for ourselves our family's new geometry, just like any family that has suffered a loss. Other families feel the opposite. The world's attention validated the size of their grief. We understood this and respected it. And we just chose another, quieter way-- at least until my father got sick and couldn't stop blurting it out over and over to strangers in parking lots.
在随后的日子和岁月里，这与其说是一个咒语，不如说是我们唯一的生存之道，寻找一种方法将发生的事情与发生在我们身上的事情分离开来。我们拒绝参与大多数仪式和盛会，转而自己寻找我们家庭的新轨迹，就像任何遭受损失的家庭一样。其他家庭感受截然相反。世界的关注证实了他们悲伤的规模。我们理解这一点并尊重它。我们只是选择了另一种更安静的方式——直到我父亲病倒，无法停止在停车场里一遍又一遍地向陌生人脱口而出。
Which is why the corner of Greenwich and Liberty on this bright Sunday afternoon, surrounded by a riot of mid-spring tourists with winkled maps and exposed knees, taking photos of cranes, is the very last place I should be. I am allowed to enter the 9/11 museum a few days before the grand opening for the general public, but why would I want that? Why would I accept an invitation to a $700 million refutation of everything we tried to practice, a gleaming monument to what happened, not what happened to us?
这就是为什么这个阳光明媚的周日下午，在格林威治街和自由街的拐角处，被一群带着皱巴巴的地图、膝盖外露、为起重机拍照的暮春游客所包围，是我最不应该出现的地方。我可以在公众开放前几天进入9/11博物馆，但我为什么要那样做呢？为什么我要接受邀请去参加一个7亿美元、驳斥我们尝试践行的一切的纪念馆，一个闪闪发光的纪念“发生了什么”而不是“发生了什么在我们身上”的丰碑？
But something snapped while reading about the gift shop. I didn't want to duck and hide, I wanted to run straight into the absurdity and horror and feel every bit of the righteous indignation and come out the other side raw. I call my mother to tell her I'm doing this, but that she shouldn't come. And she doesn't disagree. I find the ticket booth, exhale deeply, and say the magic words.
但在读到关于礼品店的内容时，有些东西断了。我不想躲躲闪闪，我想直接冲进那种荒谬和恐怖中，感受每一分义愤填膺，然后从另一边赤裸地走出来。我给母亲打电话告诉她我在做这件事，但她不应该来。她并不反对。我找到了售票亭，深呼吸，说了魔咒。
After the TSA-style security check, complete with body scan, there's a dark corridor with word clouds and photographs projected onto tower-like pillars, while disembodied voices tell snippets of stories about the morning-- an overture warning us about the symphony ahead. We were eased into it in a sense, lowered into the maw down a ramp along the original foundation of the towers-- girders and rubble and broken staircases among the ruins, an impossibly mangled hook-and-ladder truck, showroom parked.
在TSA式的安检之后，完成了全身扫描，有一条漆黑的走廊，文字云和照片投射在塔状柱子上，无声的声音讲述着关于那天早晨的故事片段——一个警告我们接下来交响乐的前奏。从某种意义上说，我们被轻松引入其中，沿着塔楼原始地基的坡道向下进入深处——废墟中的钢梁、瓦砾和破碎的楼梯，一辆不可思议地扭曲的钩梯车，像陈列室一样停放着。
The crowded memorial hall is lined with photos of everyone who died and touchscreen consoles that call up their obituaries. I find my sister as she has been for 12 and 1/2 years and will be forever-- enshrined alphabetically before Howard Lee Kane. The names are read aloud on a loop in the adjacent darkened atrium lined with benches. My sister's profile has incorrect information in it that we'd never signed off on or even seen. And the annoyance is tempered by the realization that non-participation in the pageantry has its drawbacks. It also occurs to me that I am the only person here alone.
拥挤的纪念馆大厅里挂满了所有遇难者的照片，还有可以调出他们讣告的触摸屏控制台。我找到了我姐姐，她已经这样12年半了，并将永远如此——在霍华德·李·凯恩（Howard Lee Kane）之前按字母顺序供奉。名字在相邻的黑暗中庭里循环播放，那里排满了长椅。我姐姐的档案资料有错误的信息，我们从未签字确认或甚至见过。这种恼怒被一种“不参与盛会是有代价的”认识所缓和。我也意识到我是这里唯一独自一人的人。
The main attraction is through a revolving door, a minute-by-minute recreation of the morning and its aftermath, from video of Matt Lauer's first distracted, furrowed brow at the end of an interview with some author on The Today Show, and on and on. This part is the haunted house. I wander to a tucked away corner to find a giant photo of people leaping from the burning building, and I yell, "Fuck!" like someone jumped out and grabbed me. No one bats an eye.
主要景点通过旋转门，是那天早晨及其后果的逐分钟重现，从马特·劳尔（Matt Lauer）在《今日秀》上采访某位作者结束时，那个心烦意乱、眉头紧锁的片段，等等等等。这一部分是鬼屋。我漫步到一个偏僻的角落，发现一张人们从燃烧的大楼中跳下的巨大照片，我大喊一声，“操！”就像有人跳出来抓住了我。没人注意。
There's a multimedia presentation depicting how, precisely, the towers collapsed. A wing for Pennsylvania and the Pentagon, tape loops of survivors telling how they got out, smoke and fire and ash and twisted metal and the husk of an ambulance. Tattered flags, handwritten pleas for help, missing persons flyers, screams. Dusty, ownerless Topsiders encased in glass. A soot-coated bike rack, as it was found. Countless personal artifacts artfully destroyed. The president addressing the nation and vowing steely, determined revenge. Hallways dedicated to tracing the hijackers' timeline, al-Qaeda's rise, and a video wall with people like Hillary Clinton laying out the justification for the unending war on terror, tying grief cannily to political ideology in a way that might seem crass if I were able to process it all with a clear head.
有一个多媒体展示，精确描绘了塔楼是如何倒塌的。一个关于宾夕法尼亚州和五角大楼的展区，幸存者讲述他们如何逃生的录音循环，烟雾、火焰、灰烬、扭曲的金属和救护车的残骸。破烂的旗帜，手写的求助信，失踪人员传单，尖叫声。玻璃柜里装着布满灰尘、没有主人的船鞋。一个覆盖着煤灰的自行车架，就像它被发现时那样。无数私人物品被艺术地摧毁。总统向全国发表讲话，发誓要进行钢铁般坚定的复仇。走廊致力于追踪劫机者的行踪、基地组织的兴起，以及一面视频墙，上面有希拉里·克林顿（Hillary Clinton）这样的人陈述反恐战争的理由，将悲伤狡黠地与政治意识形态联系起来，如果我能用清醒的头脑处理这一切，这可能会显得粗俗。
There is no way out until the end. And it's all so numbing that maybe this is the whole point. The exhibition starts with one shining, unfathomably terrible morning and winds up as all of our lives, as banal and constant as laundry, bottomless. I can feel the sweat that went into making this not seem tacky, of wanting to show respect, but also wanting to show every last bit of carnage and visceral whomp to justify the $24 price of admission.
直到最后都没有出路。这一切都让人麻木，也许这就是全部意义所在。展览以一个明亮、深不可测的糟糕早晨开始，最后变成我们所有人的生活，像洗衣服一样平庸而恒定，深不见底。我可以感觉到为了使这看起来不庸俗而付出的汗水，想要表示尊重，但也想要展示每一寸残骸和那种 visceral whomp 以证明24美元门票的价值。
The fact that everyone else here today has VIP status grimly similar to mine is the lone saving grace. The prospect of experiencing this stroll down Waking Nightmare Lane with tuned-out schoolkids or spectacle-seekers would be too much. There are FDNY T-shirts and search-and-rescue sweatshirts. And no one quite makes eye contact with anyone else, and that's just fine.
今天在这里的每个人都有着与我惊人相似的VIP身份，这是唯一的拯救。如果是在与漫不经心的学生或寻找奇观的人一起体验这段“清醒梦魇之旅”，那将太难受了。有FDNY的T恤和搜救卫衣。没有人与其他人有真正的眼神交流，那很好。
I think now of every war memorial I ever yawned through on a class trip, how someone else's past horror was my vacant diversion. And maybe I learned something, but I didn't feel anything. Everyone should have a museum dedicated to the worst day of their life and be forced to attend it with a bunch of tourists from Denmark-- annotated divorce papers blown up and mounted, interactive exhibits detailing how your mom's last round of chemo didn't take, souvenir T-shirts emblazoned with your best friend's last words before the car crash. And you should have to see for yourself how little your pain matters to a family of five who just need to get some food before the kids melt down. Or maybe worse, watch that pain be co-opted by people who want, for whatever reason, to feel that connection so acutely.
我现在想到每一个我在班级旅行中打哈欠经过的战争纪念馆，别人过去的恐怖是如何成了我空洞的消遣。也许我学到了什么，但我什么都没感觉到。每个人都应该有一家专门纪念他们生命中最糟糕的一天的博物馆，并被迫和一群来自丹麦的游客一起参观——被放大并装裱的注释离婚文件，详细说明你妈妈最后一轮化疗为什么没起效的互动展览，印有你最好朋友在车祸前最后一句话的纪念T恤。你应该亲眼看看你的痛苦对一家只需要在孩子崩溃前吃点东西的五口之家来说有多重要。或者更糟糕的是，看着那种痛苦被那些无论出于何种原因，想要如此强烈地感受到那种联系的人所利用。
There are three recording booths for people to tell their own stories of the day or remembrances of loved ones who were lost. A man exits one of the confessionals, sees me, shakes his head and says, "Amazing idea." I enter, sit down, and stare at the screen and say Shari's name and how I was 3,000 miles away that morning and didn't even know she was working there until I got the call at 6:00 AM, and that I wish I had seen her more in those last years and remembered more about her and had something better prepared to say, and that I wished my kids would have known her, and that she'd think it's pretty fucking weird that I'm here talking about her to an invisible camera in the bowels of a museum dedicated to the fact that she was killed by an airplane while sitting at her desk. And at some point, the timer is up.
有三个录音亭供人们讲述他们自己的那天的故事，或者对失去的亲人的怀念。一个男人走出其中一个忏悔室，看见我，摇了摇头说：“惊人的想法。”我进去，坐下，盯着屏幕，说了莎丽的名字，说了那天早上我在3000英里之外，直到早上6点接到电话才知道她在那里工作，说我希望在最后几年里多见见她，多记住她一点，并准备了更好的话，希望我的孩子们能认识她，她会觉得我在这里对着一个虚无的摄像头谈论她——在博物馆的深处，致力于她坐在办公桌前被飞机杀死的事实——真是太他妈诡异了。在某个时候，计时结束了。
There is one small room on the main floor of the museum that is not, in fact, operated by the museum itself and is not available even to many of the families. Tucked away off to the side, behind an unmarked door, it is overseen by the medical examiner's office. This is called the reflection room. To get past the door, one must register for an appointment. I have not done this, but I present a case number, which means the official from the medical examiner's office can indeed let me through. He tells me my family is welcome whenever the museum is open and leads me to a cramped, dark space but does not follow.
博物馆主楼有一个小房间，实际上并不是由博物馆本身运营的，甚至不对许多家庭开放。藏在侧面，一扇没有标记的门后，由法医办公室监管。这被称为反思室。要通过这扇门，必须预约。我没这样做，但我提供了一个案件编号，这意味着法医办公室的官员确实可以让我进去。他告诉我我的家人在博物馆开放时随时受到欢迎，并领我到一个狭窄、黑暗的空间，但没有跟进来。
A box of tissues sits on a wooden bench, and a family huddle silently looking through a window. They leave almost instantly, and I can now see what is on the other side of the window-- aisles of dark-stained wood cabinets of rosewood or teak, maybe, floor to ceiling, lit by small, overhead spotlights. I let out a loud, sharp laugh. Inside these cabinets are the remains that, after nearly 13 years of the most rigorous testing known to man, have not been matched to the DNA of any of the victims. It's just drawers and drawers full of stuff.
木凳上放着一盒纸巾，一个家庭正默默地聚在一起透过窗户看。他们几乎立刻离开了，我现在可以看到窗户另一边是什么——成排的深色木柜，也许是红木或柚木，从地板到天花板，由小型头顶聚光灯照亮。我发出一声响亮、尖锐的笑声。这些柜子里装的是经过近13年已知最严格测试后，仍未与任何受害者DNA匹配的遗骸。全是满满的抽屉，塞满了东西。
This chamber is meant to be a sanctuary, but all there is to see here are armoires packed with carefully-label bags of flesh too ruined and desiccated even for science. My sister is among the many for whom there have been no remains recovered whatsoever-- vaporized. So there's no grave to visit. There never will be-- just this theatrically lit Ikea warehouse behind a pane of glass.
这个房间本意是避难所，但这里能看到的只有塞满了标好标签的肉袋的橱柜，它们因为太毁损和干燥，连科学都无法利用。我姐姐在那些没有任何遗骸被发现的许多人之中——蒸发了。所以没有坟墓可以去祭拜。永远不会有了——只有这扇玻璃窗后照明戏剧化的宜家仓库。
The presence of the tomb has been a point of contention among families who want more from a final resting place than the basement of this museum of unnatural history. I don't know how to feel about the matter because to do so would require any of this making even a bit of sense. It's dumb, sure, but what could possibly be less dumb? Where is the right place to store pounds of unidentifiable human tissue so that future generations can pay their respects?
坟墓的存在在希望有一个比这个非自然历史博物馆地下室更好的安息之地的家庭中一直是一个争论点。我不知道该对此有何感想，因为那样做需要这一切哪怕有一点道理。这很愚蠢，当然，但还有什么能比这更不愚蠢的呢？存储数磅无法辨认的人体组织以便子孙后代祭奠的正确地方在哪里？
By the time I finally reach the gift shop, the indignation I've been counting on just isn't there. I stare at the $39 hoodies, and the rescue vests for dogs, and the earrings, and the scarves, and the United We Stand wool blankets waiting for that rush, and can't muster so much as a sigh. The events of the day have already been exploited and sold in ways previously incomprehensible. Why get mad at a commemorative T-shirt now?
当我最终到达礼品店时，我所期待的愤怒并不存在。我盯着那些39美元的连帽衫、狗用的救援背心、耳环、围巾，以及等待那种冲动的“团结一致”羊毛毯，连一声叹息都发不出。那一天的事件已经被以以前无法想象的方式利用和销售了。现在为什么还要对一件纪念T恤生气呢？
This tchotchke store, this building, this experience is nothing more than a logical endpoint for our most reliably commodifiable national tragedy. If you want to bring a coffee table book full of photos of cadaver dogs sniffing through smoking rubble back home to wherever you're from, hey, that's great. This is America. They hate our freedom to buy what we want.
这家小饰品店，这座建筑，这种体验只不过是我们最可靠的商品化国家悲剧的逻辑终点。如果你想把一本装满搜尸犬在冒烟瓦砾中嗅探照片的咖啡桌书带回你来的地方，嘿，那很好。这是美国。他们讨厌我们购买自己想要东西的自由。
And people will find moments of grace or enlightenment or even peace coming here. I don't need to be one of them. I'll probably bring my kids one day, once I realize I won't have the words to explain. It can be of use. It's fine. I don't know.
人们会在这里找到优雅、启蒙甚至和平的时刻。我不需要成为他们中的一员。我有一天可能会带我的孩子们来，一旦我意识到我没有语言来解释。它会有用。这很好。我不知道。
Steve Kandell is a writer and editor in New York.
史蒂夫·坎德尔是纽约的一名作家和编辑。
Our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman and Chana Joffe-Walt. Our program was put together by Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Alvin Melathe, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Mixing help today from Stowe Nelson Katherine Rae Mondo and Sharif Youssef.
我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）和查纳·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）制作。我们的节目由本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、阿尔文·梅拉斯（Alvin Melathe）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）组装。我们的资深制片人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的总编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。今天的混音帮助来自斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·瑞·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）和谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Youssef）。
Special thanks today to Keeli Shaw, Sundar Ramun, Kathryn Braund, Scotty Kirkland, Dr. Deidra Suwanee Dees, Guy Hubbs, Jason Edward Black, Christopher D. Haveman, Will Dahlberg, Tilia Wilton-Johnson , Otto Grimwood , Brandi Mack, Rose Thornwell, Jerry Wolfe, Mark Rader, Roy Arce, Jay Shilliday, Sam Greenspan, and Lauren Elliott at Amblin Partners.
特别感谢基利·肖（Keeli Shaw）、桑达尔·拉蒙（Sundar Ramun）、凯瑟琳·布劳恩（Kathryn Braund）、斯科蒂·柯克兰（Scotty Kirkland）、戴德拉·苏瓦尼·迪斯博士（Dr. Deidra Suwanee Dees）、盖伊·哈布斯（Guy Hubbs）、杰森·爱德华·布莱克（Jason Edward Black）、克里斯托弗·D·哈夫曼（Christopher D. Haveman）、威尔·达尔伯格（Will Dahlberg）、蒂莉亚·威尔顿-约翰逊（Tilia Wilton-Johnson）、奥托·格里姆伍德（Otto Grimwood）、布兰迪·麦克（Brandi Mack）、罗斯·索恩威尔（Rose Thornwell）、杰里·沃尔夫（Jerry Wolfe）、马克·雷德（Mark Rader）、罗伊·阿尔斯（Roy Arce）、杰伊·希利迪（Jay Shilliday）、山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和安布林合伙公司（Amblin Partners）的劳伦·埃利奥特（Lauren Elliott）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I made him a martini. He always wants extra ice in the shaker. Always extra ice. I know he likes it when he says--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，我给他做了一杯马提尼。他总是要在摇壶里加额外的冰。总是额外的冰。我知道当他说——的时候他很喜欢——
Aww, man, that was cold.
噢，伙计，那太冷血了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。